avec noyonnais sa belle fellah
économiste spécialiste du monde arabe et
françois costantini géopolitologue
bonsoir messieurs merci de participer à
cet échange ce soir troisième réunion
d'urgence aujourd'hui du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et toujours pas de
proposition pour faire cesser les
hostilités on a tendu le ministre
chinois des affaires étrangères deere
deere regretté l'obstruction des états
unis pour faire adopter une résolution
quelle est la posture aujourd'hui des
états unis se sont eux essentiellement
qui bloque à l'onu france à constantine
et de soul à huy à une résolution qui
apparaît sorte partager ou qui partager
les responsabilités il est certain que
les états unis mettront leur veto les
etats-unis considèrent que c'est en
effet israël qui doit être défendue en
premier option qui peut se justifier
mais qui doit pas être exclusive
il ya en effet des raisons de fond des
raisons beaucoup plus profonde qui
tiennent aux circonstances actuelles et
puis à des mets a défait structurelles
qui date de plusieurs décennies c'est
pratiquement une guerre de 100 ans qui a
commencé au lendemain d'un lapin guerre
mondiale sur coeur qui a été pour
reprendre les termes de charge or big
beaucoup trop promise donc en effet en
ce n'est pas véritablement le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui peut
hélas malheureusement sortir le la
région de l'ornière rappelons quand même
que la la la seule résolution qui
avaient des deux seuls résolution qui a
été adoptée et qui sont restés en
histoire sont la résolution sont 93 de
l'assemblée générale à l'époque avait
créé le plan de partage de la palestine
et la résolution de son terme de 2067
qui devrait constituer le socle de tout
accord à la région n'en résout joe biden
le président américain s'est entretenu
hier à la fois avec le chef de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas
avec aussi à le premier ministre est
très bien benyamin nétanyahou mais qui
par là où hamas younes belle fait là est
ce que le conflit peut se résoudre si le
hamas qui rappelons le est considéré
comme une organisation terroriste n'est
pas inclus dans les discussions
bonsoir
je crois effectivement parce que là on
parle d'un conflit entre israël et
palestine mais la réalité c'est qu'on
est en train de voir un conflit entre
israël et le mouvement du hamas parce
que l'autorité nationale palestinienne
qui est normalement l' autorité
illégitime ont reconnu par les nations
c'est lui est reconnu par les pays
arabes comme étant représentant légitime
des palestiniens n'a pas réagi par
rapport à ce qui se passe au palestine
non intervient pas militairement dans la
seine dans la scène militaire est
également
on voit aussi qu'il ya aussi une
coordination sécuritaire entre cette
autorité est entre le côté israélien
cercle rouge des états unis est large et
très important depuis la signature des
palestiniens des accords de ce taux on
rappelle bien de ces accords qui ont
donné la légitimité à l'autorité
nationale palestinienne et a une
représentation diplomatique de cette
autorité
les etats unis détiennent la majorité
écrasante des cartes de ce conflit entre
les israéliens et les palestiniens mais
je crois que la grande transformation
dans cette cause palestinienne c'était
en 2006 une fois où le hamas à monter au
pouvoir ce qui a signifié en quelque
sorte
l'islamisation de la cause palestinienne
et donc c'est ce qui pose maintenant
même problème par rapport à certains
pays de réagir ou de prendre une
position vis-à-vis de tout ce qui se
passe
sachant bien que l'intervention de
amasseront la cause palestinienne
une cause régionale le hamas est
soutenue militairement par l'iran
financièrement par le qatar
politiquement par la turquie et donc on
trouve que cette intervention on va dire
régionales dans cet abandon ce conflit
rolala la possibilité d'avoir une
solution politique de plus en plus très
très difficile
maintenant je rappelle qu'ils avaient ce
qu'on appelle le quartet qui était signé
le quarté pour le moyen-orient prix a
été fait en 2002 entre les nations unies
les états unis l'union européenne et la
russie et qui a normalement travailler à
pour une démarche on va dire de paix qui
se constituent sur trois principes
fondamentaux
d'abord la non violence et la lutte
contre le terrorisme
la reconnaissance de l'état d'israël est
bien évidemment le respect des accords
précédemment signés il s'agit bien
évidemment des accords d'oslo signés
entre les palestiniens et les israéliens
il faut rappeler aussi que c'était la
guerre vient en quelque sorte dans un
contexte normalement où il y avait une
possibilité de paix entre les pays
arabes et élise et rallier à l'année
dernière on l'a vu des pays comme les
émirats arabes unis le maroc le tout
dans le bahreïn qui s'ajoutent à des
pays comme la jordanie et l'egypte qui
devient maintenant des pays qui ont des
liens diplomatiques avec avec avec
israël et qui aspire à avoir des
relations et économiques et commerciales
et là maintenant effectivement ce genre
de tension accrue peut créer
certainement une déstabilisation de 7,2
cette région pas seulement pour les
palestiniens mais également dans une
région poudrière dont il ya aussi
d'autres dossiers le liban l'irak et la
syrie
est-ce que l'egypte pourrait jouer ce
rôle de médiateur françois constantini
c'est l'un des seuls pays à s'adresser à
toutes les composantes de ce conflit oui
les jt aujourd'hui en tout cas comme le
seul médiateur mais les relations entre
l'egypte et le hamas sont compliquées on
sait qu'il y avait notamment des tunnels
entre la bande de gaza l'egypte qui ont
été détruits depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
de dumouchel six tenues ou qui a extirpé
en effet du court
les frères musulmans qui s'étaient
installés et qui eux d'ailleurs étaient
prêts à apporter un soutien beaucoup
plus conséquents ont ramassé aux
palestiniens de gaza alors la médiation
n'est pas si facile parce que l'egypte
n'est pas tout à fait acquis distance
entre israël et le hamas
elle est en paix avec israël avec le
maréchal à cécile à une les choses sont
en effet apaisé et l'egypte apal alors
qu'elle n'avait été il ya un yak 40 ans
il est aujourd'hui à la tête de pont la
première cordée dans ce qu'on appelle la
ligne désaccord abraham donc en fait
elle était le précurseur la médiation
paraît difficile de la part de la part
de l'egypte
le gardien
mas avoir des accords de désescalade
alors peut-être le fait de l'autorité
palestinienne s'est côtoyé compassionnel
comme l'a dit monsieur avant en fait
nous n'avons pas deux entités mais trois
entités ce qu'on appelle l'ensemble de
la palestine mandataire
l'état israélien et l'autorité
palestinienne dirigée par le principe
allemand le fatah mahmoud abbas mais qui
est affaibli et gaza qui est tenu par le
hamas et nous nous éponge ont en fait
les conséquences du retrait unilatéral
et quitte israël de la bande de gaza en
à l'époque c'est ariel sharon qui est
bien et quelques mois plus tard le
ponctuel que l'ol paie a été
littéralement chassé les armes à la main
par le fatah de gaza
en fait les deux ans nous entendent pas
mais je pense qu'il fera dans un premier
temps l'autorité pas et si la normale
sur l'ensemble du peuple palestinien
elle en a en tout cas là on a à z en
tout cas la seule légitime soutenant et
la médiation de l'egypte paraît en effet
parsemé d'embûches pour revenir sur ce
qui se joue en ce moment sur le terrain
on évoque près de trois mille roquettes
lancées par des groupes armés
palestiniens en direction d'israël des
roquettes lancées parfois à très longue
distance d'où vient cette force de
frappe du hamas younes el fellah
certainement l'armement du hamas a connu
une évolution qualitative ans si on voit
la guerre par exemple de 2014
bien avant en 2000 2008 on voit
certainement qu'il ya un développement
d'armements et ça bien sûr ça devient
parce qu'il ya à l'heure hamas à
développer des relations stratégiques
avec avec l'iran et avec la turquie et
le qatar qui représente un soutien
financier et militaire est également
politique pour 7 pour cette organisation
qui a maintenant la mainmise sur toute
la bande de du gaz 1 on se rappelle bien
qu'il avait des rapports qui ont été
faits par par exemple et human rights
watch ou bien amnesty international qui
ont épinglé le rôle du hamas dans la
bande de gaza à travers à l'islamisation
on vient la torture de certains des
activistes
des défenseurs de droits de l'homme dont
sept dans cette bande de gaza et mais
jusqu'aujourd'hui effectivement il n'ya
pas une réaction aussi nos parts de
certains pays européens
il ya c'est vrai qu'il ya une division
au niveau de l'union européenne et à des
pays qui reconnaît le hamas comme étant
une organisation terroriste et d'autres
non dans le cas également de la france
qui ne reconnaît pas s'être que le hamas
comme étant une organisation terroriste
et hic ce qu'il est en quelque sorte le
fait que ce mouvement profitent de
certains font parfois européen de cet
hameçon harati sont normalement orientés
vers des raisons humanitaires tant que
ça après pour une transformation vers
l'armement ou via ouvert à
l'islamisation de 7,2 cette affaire
sachant bien qu'il ya une grande des
divisions entre l'autorité nationale
palestinienne et le hamas sur le champ
politique
il y avait également normalement une des
élections qui auraient été programmée
pour le mois de mai a été reportée par
un malouda dont normalement le principal
concurrent pour l'autorité nationale
c'est effectivement le hamas
maintenant sur un point de vue
international je crois que l'union
européenne divisée par rapport à ce qui
se passe au niveau de conflit palestino
israélien parce qu'il ya des pays qui
ont manifesté clairement leur soutien
pour lui les israéliens les positions
par exemple des pays de l'europe de
l'est sont clairement pro israélien
l'autriche également aujourd'hui je
crois que la france normalement peut
jouer un rôle très important par rapport
à cette atteinte à faire dessus est que
historiquement il ya toujours un lien
culturel politique vers cette région
mais ce que je veux vraiment souligner
c'est que normalement la le conflit
israélo-palestinien ne doit pas être un
objet politique et électoral en france
parce que vraiment les réactions de
certains députés ou de certains maires
de villes qui cherche à stimuler parfois
des votes musulmans ou de votre juge n'a
aucune raison
bon la politique étrangère elle se fait
par le président et par le mien pour
revenir sur ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est tension est extrêmement vive entre
israéliens et palestiniens françois
costantini
comment est-ce que ça qu'elle regarde
que vous portez sur cette posture très
martial des israéliens quel est
l'objectif d'israël aujourd'hui c'est de
détruire finalement toutes les
plateformes de lancement de roquettes du
hamas qui conduirait peut-être de fait à
une désescalade des violences ces
prochains jours
oui je pense je pense que à partir
le hamas tient la bande de gaza israël
considère que le hamas exclusivement
responsables
la dégradation de la sécurité en effet
israël et intérêt d'ailleurs dans sa
peau de l'offensive des dinances en
dansant brooke est généralisé de la part
du hamas pour détruire un certain nombre
de points de ma stratégie comme elle a
commencé à le faire le chef du hamas
les services de renseignements les
brigades de sécurité les brigades de
l'essence du hamas les principaux points
névralgiques du hamas ont été attaqués
et là dessus israël sur l'implacable
elle visera autant que possible le hamas
le hamas à la tête et ses
infrastructures première au théâtre
c'est tout à fait énorme et beaucoup
plus par exemple joxi manoir est bonne
c'est beaucoup plus je crois que les
langues de roquettes qui avaient été
tirées par le hezbollah en 2006 lors de
la guerre entre israël et le hezbollah
c'est à dire que le gaza le hamas n'a
pas une capacité des nations destruction
mais il a une forte capacité de nuisance
en tout cas de déstabilisation en israël
la sécurité en volant la quasi-fermeture
d'ailleurs de l'espace aérien israélien
ce qui ne s'était jamais vu avant même
d'ailleurs pratiquement ou de la guerre
entre israël et le hezbollah
mais israël en effet la paix israël de
faire ôter la responsabilité sur le
hamas et de réduire en effet les mes
capacités de nuisance et les capacités
offensives de la fin merci à tous les
deux messieurs d'avoir participé à cet
échange ce soir françois à costantini je
rappelle que vous êtes
géopolitologue youn et sa belle fille la
économiste spécialiste du monde arabe
merci à tous les deux et à bientôt sur
rt france